[Music]
so welcome everyone to our session on
next generation CI CD with gke and
Tecton so I'm Kim Lewandowski and I'm a
product manager at Google and hey
everybody I'm Christie Wilson I'm also
from Google cloud and I'm an engineering
lead on tech time so before we get
started a quick show of hands how many
of you are running kubernetes workloads
today Wow quite a few awesome and how
many of you are practicing see icd ok
awesome and then using Jenkins nice
something else ok cool good mix so today
we're going to cover some basics we're
going to talk about a new project called
Tecton that we've been working on we're
excited we have two guest speakers
joining us today to talk about their
integrations with Tecton we're gonna
briefly cover Tecton governance and then
finally what's in the pipeline for us so
we're here to talk to you about the next
generation of CI CD and we think that
the key to taking a huge leap forward
with CI CD is cloud native technology so
I for one found myself using this term
cloud native all the time but I realized
that I didn't actually know what it
meant so this is specifically what cloud
native means applications that are cloud
native are open source their
architecture is micro services in
containers as opposed to monolithic apps
on VMs those containers are dynamically
orchestrated and we optimize resource
utilization and scale as needed the key
to all of this is containers containers
have really changed the way that we
distribute software so instead of
building system specific binaries and
then installing those and installing a
web of dependencies we can package up
the binaries with all of their
dependencies and configuration that they
need and then distribute that but what
do you do if you have a lot of
containers
that's where kubernetes comes in so
kubernetes is a platform for dynamically
orchestrating containers you can tell it
how to run
your container what other services it
needs what storage it needs and
kubernetes takes care of the rest and
then in addition to that kubernetes
abstracts away the underlying hardware
so you get functionality like if a
machine that's running your container
goes down it'll be automatically
rescheduled to a machine that's up and
in Google Cloud we have a hosted
offering of kubernetes called google
kubernetes engine or gke so this is what
cloud native ends up looking like for
most of us we use containers as our most
basic building block then we dynamically
orchestrate those containers with
kubernetes and control our resource
utilization and these are the
technologies that we're using to build
cloud native sea icd so for those not
familiar with CIC and it sounds like
most of you are it's really a set of
practices to get your code built tested
and deployed so CI pipelines are usually
kicked off after a pre submit workflow
and determine what code can be merged
into a branch and then there's CD which
is what code changes you then deploy to
a branch either automatically or
manually and so what we've learned is
that there's not really a
one-size-fits-all solution there are
projects that just want something simple
and just something that works out of the
box and then there are companies with
really complex requirements and
processes that they must follow as their
code travels from source to production
so it's an exciting time for us in this
new cloud native world for CI CD so CI
CD systems are really going through a
transformation CI systems can now be
centered around containers and we can
dynamically orchestrate those containers
and using service methodologies control
ru search use resource costs and with
well-defined conformant api's we can
take advantage of that power and not be
locked in but in this new world there's
a lot of room for improvement problems
that existed before are still true today
and some are just downright harder if we
break our services into micro services
they inherently consist of more pieces
have more dependencies and can be
difficult to manage
and the terminology is all over the
place the same words can mean different
things depending on the tool and there
are a lot of tools it seems like every
week a new tool is announced so I can't
even keep up with all of them and I know
that our customers are having challenges
making their own tooling decisions so
it's great to have this many choices but
it can often lead to fragmentation
confusion and complexity but when you
squint at all these continuous delivery
foundation or solutions at their core
they all start to look the same they
have a concept of source code access
artifacts build results etc but the end
goal is always the same get my code from
source to production as quickly and
securely as possible so at Google we
took a step back and after a few
brainstorming sessions we asked
ourselves if we could do the same thing
to CIS CD that kubernetes did with
containers that is could we collaborate
with industry leaders in the open to
define a common set of components and
guidelines for CI CD systems to build
test and deploy code anywhere and that
is what the Tecton project is all about
Tecton is a shared set of open source
cloud native building blocks for CI a CD
systems even though Tecton runs on
kubernetes the goal is to target any
platform any language and any framework
whether that's gke on Prem multi cloud
hybrid cloud tribrid cloud you name it
so Tecton started as a project with
inkay native people who got very excited
to be able to build images on kubernetes
and but very quickly they wanted to do
more they wanted to run tests on those
images and they wanted to define more
complex pipelines and it's enthusiasm
grew we decided to move it out and put
it into its own github org and where it
became Tecton so there again the vision
of this project is CI CD building blocks
that are composable declarative and
reproducible we want to make it super
easy and fast to build custom extensible
layers on top of these building blocks
so engineers can take an entire CI to
see a CD pipeline and run it against
their own infrastructure or they can
take pieces of that pipeline and run it
in isolation in the more vendors that
support Tecton the more choices users
will have and they'll be able to plug
and play different pieces from multiple
vendors with the same pipeline
definition underneath so Tecton is a
collaborative effort and we're already
working on this project with companies
including cloudBees Red Hat and Ibn and
we made a super big effort to make it
easy for new contributors to join us and
again pipelines is our first building
block for Tecton and now Christy will be
diving deeper so Tecton pipelines is all
about cloud native components for
defining CI CD pipelines so I'm going to
go into a bit of detail about how it
works and how its implemented so the
first thing to understand is that it's
implemented using kubernetes c RDS
so c r d stands for custom resource
definition and it's a way of extending
kubernetes itself so out of the box
kubernetes comes with resources like
pods deployments and services but
through CR DS you can define your own
resources and then you create binary
skald controllers that act on those
resources so what's the RDS have we
added for Tecton pipelines our most
basic building block is something we
call a step so this is actually a
kubernetes container spec which is an
existing type a container spec lets you
specify an image and everything you need
to run it like what environment
variables to use what arguments what
volumes etc and the first new type we
added is called a task so a task lets
you combine steps you define a sequence
of steps which run in sequential order
on the same kubernetes node our next new
type is called a pipeline a pipeline
lets you combine tasks together and you
can define the order that these tasks
run in so that can be sequentially it
can be concurrently or you can create
complicated graphs the tasks
aren't guaranteed to execute on the same
note but through the pipeline you can
take the outputs from one task and you
can pass them as inputs to the next task
so being able to define these more
complex graphs will really speed up your
pipelines so for example in this
pipeline we can get some of the faster
activities out of the way in parallel
first like linting and running unit
tests next as we run into some of the
slower steps like running integration
tests we can do some of our other slower
activities like building images and
setting up the test environment for our
end-to-end tests so tasks and pipelines
are types you define once and you use
again and again to actually invoke those
you use pipeline runs and task runs
which are our next new types so these
actually invoke the pipelines and tasks
but to do that you need runtime
information like what image registry
should I use what git repo should I be
running against and to do that you use
our fifth and final type pipeline
resources so altogether we added 5 CR DS
we have tasks which are made up of steps
we have pipelines which are made up of
tasks then we invoke those using task
runs and pipeline runs and finally we
provide runtime information with
pipeline resources and decoupling this
runtime information gives us a lot of
power because suddenly you can take the
same pipeline that you use to push to
production and you can safely run it
against your PO requests or you can
shift even further left and suddenly
your contributors can run that same
pipeline against their own
infrastructure so this is what the
architecture looks like at a very high
level so users interact with kubernetes
to create pipelines and tasks which are
stored in kubernetes itself and then
when the user wants to run them the user
creates the runs which are picked up by
a controller which is managed by
kubernetes and the controller realizes
them by creating the appropriate pods
and container instances
cool so today I'm excited to welcome
engineers from cloudBees and trigger
mesh to talk about how they've been
integrating with the Tecton project and
I want to highlight that they were able
to do this very quickly because we put a
ton of time in ever into onboarding new
collaborators so first I'd like to
introduce Andrew bare on stage to talk
to us about Jenkins X and Jenko jenkin X
is integrating with Tecton so hi I'm
Andrew bear I'm an engineer at cloud
peas working on pipelines both in
Jenkins and Jacob Zacks so who hears
heard of Jenkins X that's that's a lot
of people who here's played with it a or
is using it etc it's good it's good
so in case you're not familiar with
Jenkins ax let me try and probably fail
to explain it very well and then get
corrected Jake it's X is a new CI CD
experience for kubernetes it's designed
to run on kubernetes and target
kubernetes you can do use it for
building traditional and cloud native
workloads you can create new
applications or import existing
applications into kubernetes and take
advantage of various quick starts and
build packs that allow you to get the
initial setup of the project etc without
having to do it all by hand
you see fully automated CI CD
integrating with github yeah by a prow
so a lot of automation and get-ups
promotions etc without you actually
having to go click stuff by hand
it's got promotions it's got staging dev
and prod environment integration and a
whole lot of other magic I'm here
specifically to talk about the part
about how Jenkins X is using Tecton
pipeline so a user is not actually going
to necessarily know that they're using
Tecton pipelines behind the scenes we
have our own ways of defining your
pipelines in Jenkins X either by a
standard build pack or when you define
your own pipeline using our llamó syntax
then at runtime when a bill gets kicked
off Jenkins axe translates that pipeline
into the CR DS that are necessary to run
a Tecton pipeline and then Jenkins X
monitors the pipeline execution etc so
that means that like I said the user
isn't directly interacting with Tecton
the users interacting with Jenkins acts
that means that we can do a lot of
things on our side without having to
worry about exactly how the users gonna
interact so why are we using Tecton
pipelines like I said I've been working
on
Jenkins pipelines as well for a while
now and what we've come to learn is that
pipeline execution really should be
standardized and commoditized CIC
d-tools all over the place have
reinvented the wheel many times and
there's no reason for us to keep doing
that so I'm really excited about that
and we really like that we can translate
our syntax into what's necessary for the
pipelines to actually execute so that
we're still able to provide an
opinionated and curated experience for
Jenkins X users and pipeline authors
without having them to worry about being
exactly the right syntax and verbosity
etc and it gets us away from the
traditional Jenkins world of a
long-running JVM controlling all
execution which is you know good but the
best part is as Kim mentioned how great
it is to contribute and get involved
with Tecton pipelines I only got
involved with this at all starting in
November and we've been able to
contribute significantly to the project
helped with their figuring out direction
fixing bugs integrating it with Jenkins
X and get this all to the point of being
pretty much production ready in just a
few months and that's phenomenal it's
just been a great experience and
incredibly welcoming community and
and just been a lot of fun I don't have
an actual demo exactly let me go back
again sorry I don't of course my screen
went to sleep hold on typo
all right so what I wanted to show you
here was just quickly how much of a
difference there is between the syntax a
user is authoring and what Tecton
actually needs to run and why we think
that's valuable so this is roughly what
a obviously brain-dead simple pipeline
in Jenkins X would look like just you
know 26 lines and then when we transform
it well it's a lot more than that but
because we're able to generate that and
not require the user to author it all by
hand we're able to inject Jenkins X's
opinions about environments variables
about where your what images should be
used and a lot more and it's been really
great for us to be able to have the full
power of techsan pipelines behind the
scenes and during execution without
needing to make the user have to worry
about all of those details all the time
so that's been really productive for us
so thank you
so next I'd like to introduce Chris from
trigger mesh to talk about the work he's
been doing yeah so thank you Kim
thanks Andrew hi everyone my name is
Chris Bambara developer with trigger
mesh and also one of the co-authors for
the tech tip on our sorry for turgor
meshes action so starting off with
trigger meshes action this came out as
more of a way of tying in the github
actions sorry yeah the github action
workflow once it was announced last
October into creating a way of being
able to bind that with the Tecton
pipeline approach the idea being that
with that workflow we can translate that
into the various resources that the
Tecton pipeline now makes available and
then be able to feed that into your
kubernetes cluster and be able to either
experiment with it or even create
additional hooks so that it can actually
receives external stimuli through
something like K natives eventing
service things such as like whether it
is going to be a pull request from
something like github or maybe it is
some other web form being filled out
that triggers that build or that
workflow in the background to provide
the result and ultimately allowing you
to run things from anywhere so a little
bit of a bit of a mapping exercise for
the terminology goes with github actions
you have the concept of the workflow the
workflow it would be like the equivalent
of the Tecton pipelines global pipeline
this is where anything and everything
runs task wise and then as far as the
github action that is the equivalent of
that single step or that task where it's
going to be that one container that runs
that command that produces the output
and I do call out one of the other
components within the github action
which is called uses this is more of
being able to define the image that you
want around within your tech town
pipeline task whereas with the tech town
pipeline tasks expect a particular image
what we end up translating with the
github actions or at least we will once
I finished my pull request is that we'll
be able to allow the full support that
github has for their actions as far as
being able to point it to another github
repo or appointed to and some other
local directory within that repo that
you have priest but are defined to be
able to build the docker image that you
can then feed into the pipe or the task
to work the magic as it were so as far
as our little pretty picture with the
trigger mesh action we actually have two
commands that handle everything we have
down at the bottom the create this one
creates the tasks creates the associated
pipeline resources and you can also use
it to create the tasks run or the pipe
right our pipeline run object to create
like a one-shot invocation usually if
you want to test something out to see if
you've got your workflow working just
right or if you wanted something else to
call into this and up above is we also
create a que native eventing sync as
well as The Associated transceiver
which creates a serverless service
within King native to handle the info or
the creation and the invocation of that
task run object so to give you a little
bit of a quick demo of what we have
let's see if I can Oh perfect
so what we're looking at right now is
the customary hello world example you'll
note up at the top we do have our
workflow defined this one being more of
our pipeline object the result indicates
all of the actions that would be
associated with our workflow and the on
usually indicates the type of action
that would happen within your repo and
then right below that one for the action
you'll have some kind of identifier our
naming it's the fact that we're using
CentOS is our base image and of course
we're just going to run hello with a
specific or a specification for the
environment variable we do also see that
arts does allow you to pass in either a
string or an array of strings to go in
as well which is one of the nice things
about their language and as far as like
some of our translation we take care of
that for you so with the action command
itself as mentioned before hand you have
your create you have your launch one of
the things that we originally had
started working on is our own
implementation of the parser for the
github action workflow syntax but since
github was kind enough to open source it
back in February so that experimental
projects such as these can make use of
it we've started transitioning to that
one so now it acts as more of a sanity
check on whatever workflows that you
feed in to ensure that it does what it's
supposed to do as far as the common
global arguments we do allow for passing
in your git repository when it comes to
creating things such as the collection
of tasks with the create command it is
used for being able to not only create a
pipeline resource that could be
referenced by additional steps in case
we wanted to add things to it but also
in a case of specifying like that local
directory so that we know which repo to
pull the docker from to build the image
so now we'll feed that into our hello
world we just feed everything as is and
we have our simple task object you'll
see our steps have actually been broken
down
and we have our environment variables we
have our new and improved image and we
also have our name which is Ben Cooper
95 to resemble their traditional naming
scheme and then we can pass in minus T
to provide our task for an object and
then give her favorite apply f well
hopefully it will still talk to my
kubernetes cluster and we have our
objects that are created and it looks
like it just finished so we have our
true we have our success and we also
have a pod name so we can go here and
take a look at any output in the case of
failures or if there was something that
you wanted to grab as part of the any of
the successful messages and some other
things along those lines and then if we
were to look at launch the one thing it
does require is that we do pass in a or
a task this one does also require that
you specify a github repo alright and
this one so here we have our eventing
the source definition of specific are
specifying going into github the request
for pulling in our credentials and also
the test that'll create and fire so that
believe is pretty much it
awesome so thank you Andrew and Chris
again for for sharing your work with us
like I said before we're not doing this
alone and tacked-on is actually part of
a new foundation called a continuous
delivery foundation this is an open
foundation where we're collaborating
with industry leaders on best practices
and guidelines for
the next generation of CIA CD systems
and so initial projects of the CDF
include Tecton Jenkins spinnaker and
Jenkins X now you've seen Tecton
integration with Jenkins X we're all so
excited that we're starting to integrate
with spinnaker as well and so these are
the current members of the CDF and we're
really excited to work with them on our
mission to help companies practice
continuous delivery and bring value to
their customers as fast and securely as
possible so if you do if you want to
learn more about the CDF please check
out CD dot foundation to get involved or
just kind of watch what's going on
alright so what's coming next so for the
CDF we have a co-located summit coming
up in coop con Barcelona on May 20th and
if you're interested in what's coming
down the pipeline for Tecton pipelines
or currently we're working on some
exciting features like conditional
execution and event triggering and more
and for Tecton itself we're looking
forward to expanding the scope and
adding more projects and we recently had
a dash board project added and so for
takeaways if you're interested in
contributing to Tecton or you're
interested in integrating with Tecton
please check out our contributing guide
in our github repo it has information
about how to get started developing and
also how you can join our slack channel
and our working group meetings etc if
you're an end user check out Jenkins X
check out trigger mesh action and watch
this space for more exciting Tecton
integrations in the future and that's it
thanks so much for listening to our talk
[Applause]
[Music]